[music playing]
[sirens blaring]
DAVE: (VOICEOVER)
She keeps reaching
around in the center console.
It looks like she's trying
to get something out,
maybe a handgun.
MAN: All right, GSP has a
driver out of the vehicle.
DAVE: That's our girl.
Was it loaded or no?
MAN: Oh, it was?
DAVE: There was a
loaded 38 caliber pistol
located in the center console.
All right, so he's
running the dog on him
right now on the van.
Oh, there it is.
MAN ON RADIO: Yes, so the dog
alerted on that back side door
there.
DAVE: Oh, I see a box on
the ground in the back.
Sort of looks like
they found it.
I mean, there's 20 packages, so
just depending on how much they
weigh out, I think
we're probably
going to be close to 25 kilos.
So we're taking a female
passenger and the driver
to jail.
You want him on this side?
DAVE: And they'll be
charged with trafficking,
and then the male will have
some firearms charges as well.
Everybody did what they
were supposed to do.
You know, it went as
fluid as it could have,
and, you know, we took a large
quantity of methamphetamine
off the street.
Right now, we're just
going down to the precinct.
I'll see if-- about
getting a test kit.
We'll test the drugs, see
if it's methamphetamine.
Very good for law
enforcement today, and not
so good for the bad guys.